Namo tassa bhagavato hara hatu samma sambuddhasa Namo tassa bhagavato hara hatu samma sambuddhasa Namo tassa bhagavato
Parahato Sama Sambuddhasa.
Homage to the Buddha, the blessed, noble and fully self-awakened one.
So this is the inaugural talk around verses of the Dhammapada.
And I've chosen what is probably the most famous of them all.
I shall chant it in Pali first, just to give it that Eastern flavor.
as usually translated as hatreds never cease through hatred in this world through love alone they cease this is an eternal law so this is basically a statement of non-violence
Now with each of these Dhammapada verses, there comes a little story.
So I'm very fortunate, I have this book written by Sri Dhammananda, who was a Sri Lankan monk in Malaysia.
He's died now.
And what he's done for us very kindly is he's reduced the stories to something fairly manageable.
So I shall read this as a sort of an example of
the way they would have thought or the way it was built up from perhaps a smaller original occasion.
So it's a bitter feud through various existences.
Now, once there lived a householder whose wife was barren.
Being unable to bear a child and afraid that she would be mistreated by her husband and her mother-in-law, she herself selected and arranged for her husband to marry another woman.
But on two occasions, as soon as she knew the second wife was pregnant, the barren wife gave her food mixed with drugs, causing her to have miscarriages.
On her third pregnancy, the fruitful wife kept it to herself without informing the barren wife.
But when the latter came to know of it, she again caused a miscarriage.
Eventually, the second wife died in childbirth.
Before her death, the unfortunate woman was filled with hatred and vowed vengeance on the barren wife and her future offspring.
Thus, the feud was started.
Among their later existences, the two were born as a hen and a cat, a doe and a leopardess, and finally as the daughter of a nobleman in Savarty and an ogress.
One day, the demon
was in hot pursuit of the noble bird's daughter and her baby.
When the lady heard that the Buddha was giving a religious discourse at the Jetavana monastery, she fled to him and placed her son at his feet for protection.
The demon was thus prevented from entering the monastery.
She was later called in and both Lady and Ogress were admonished by the Buddha.
The Buddha told them about their past feud as rival wives
and how they had been harboring hatred towards each other and killing each other's offspring through their various lifetimes.
They were made to see that hatred could only cause more hatred and it could only cease through friendship, understanding and goodwill.
Both realized their mistakes and on the admonition of the Buddha made their peace with each other.
The Buddha then requested the woman to hand over her son to the ogres.
Fearing for the safety of her son, she hesitated, but because of her devotion and confidence in the enlightened one, she handed over her son as directed.
The child was warmly received by the ogres.
After kissing and caressing the child tenderly, like her own very son, the ogres handed over the child back to his mother.
as a result of this episode there was much goodwill on both sides so i don't know maybe there was a kernel incident there where a desperate husband maybe went to the buddha and said my two wives are at each other all day uh can you help and uh and then it built up from there an aggressive course is a sort of uh nasty nasty female shrek i suppose um
But the story is basically about what happens when you react with hatred or anger to somebody else who's being angry or hateful.
Now, what we have to do is convince ourselves that this is true.
And I think the place to start is within ourselves.
So if you think about what happens within us when somebody is angry with us or
has a hateful attitude towards us.
See, the response is immediately, isn't it, to react with that anger, to react with hatred.
And you can see that this is just going to create more hatred and more anger because the other person now has something to chew on.
And as they respond with more hatred and anger, so we respond with more hatred and anger.
So that's a never ending process, which is just going to lead to a forest fire.
And it's really catching that within us that often for no reason, we might just dislike somebody.
And that manifests in the way we look at them, the way we actually talk to them.
And then we wonder why they're coming back to us, not recognizing that inside us, we have a very hateful attitude towards this person.
It could be because of their political stance, their religious stance.
It could be for any reason.
It could be just the way they look sometimes.
And hatred is a sort of generalized attitude that passes through time.
Anger, of course, is just a flare-up which tends to die away.
Of course, you can bring it back to mind over and over again, you know, when we're daydreaming.
But basically, these two things,
these two mental heart reactions or something that we build up within ourselves, they're looking for something to really chew on.
When the other person actually reacts to us with anger or with further hatred, then we ourselves find a reason to just continue.
And so the feud begins.
Now, there's an incident in the Buddha's life
where the dastardly Devadatta set a wild elephant on him.
Devadatta wanted to reform the order, to go back to its original ascetic practice.
Rag rogues live in just a shelter made from twigs or trees and a banana leaf put over it, really sort of go right back to those early ascetic days.
And, of course, the Buddha wouldn't accept that because the people who were ordained then just weren't really of that caliber.
So he set this wild elephant on the Buddha.
Now, the Buddha, when he saw the elephant coming, raised his hand.
So it's known as the abhaya posture, the fearless posture.
Now, that's the first thing that we have to engender towards somebody who's hateful or who's angry with us.
Somehow there has to be a feeling that they cannot destroy you, they cannot overwhelm you.
There has to be that sort of internal strength within us.
Now that might not be there, in which case we'll react in a way which is undermining ourselves.
We'll either run or hide or in some way give in to the person who's being angry with us.
you know, this is a learning process.
And the thing is to build up a certain righteousness within ourselves so that we can stand steady within ourselves, a sort of an assertiveness about ourselves within the world.
And that's difficult, you know, because, well, it's difficult.
So the elephant comes towards him and he holds his hand up.
Now, this hand is sort of also a way of him
expressing his love towards the elephant, a non-violent love towards the elephant, asking the elephant to calm down.
So it's a feeling he's sending out, a sort of beam of love.
And the elephant does slow down and finally pays obeisance.
Now, whether we want to believe these stories or not isn't really the point.
The point is that we can overcome anger, other people's anger, other people's hatred,
by non-reactivity and this idea of goodwill.
Friendliness might not be there, but definitely we can have goodwill.
Now, when somebody comes to us with that attitude of hatred and anger, it's because something is unhappy within them and they are expressing that outwards as an aggressive mental state, an aggressive mood.
So it's a case of recognizing that.
So what might we do if somebody is like that towards us?
Well, we might be quick enough to envisage this hand so that we're receiving the emotional state, right?
And that's being taken care of.
And even though we might feel inside us a certain anger growing or a certain fear growing, it's as though the hand is also guarding us against further reactions
because it's holding the other person at a distance.
Now, in order to prevent us falling into the emotion that we're engendering in ourselves, if we lift our attention and pay attention to what they're saying, in other words, to put the attention on the ear rather than the heart, then of course, what we're doing is we're being compassionate.
We're actually taking a position that maybe
If I can get in touch with the hurt that sits behind their hatred or their anger, it might undermine it.
That's an act of compassion, an act of trying to understand where the person is coming from.
And hopefully the other person will suddenly recognize that actually you're listening to them.
And that often undermines a person's anger and hatred, that finally, you know, you're actually paying attention to what their problem is.
And that often, as I say, that often just assuages the whole situation.
And then through discussion, et cetera, there can be a healing of the situation.
And that's definitely one way that you can approach a situation where a person is angry or is hateful towards you.
So I think we've been through it there, I think.
Yeah.
So we have this story of the ogres and these three qualities of friendship, understanding, you see, that's the compassion, and goodwill.
And we have the story of the Buddha overcoming the elephant.
So here we have some stories to support us, but also through our own internal investigation.
That's the way we did.
When we're angry and the other person's angry, before we know it, we're into some sort of rage.
So this whole attitude of non-violence is of absolute importance in our lives so that we can heal our own hearts of that reactivity of anger and hatred.
So if we go back to this little phrase, it's very simple, we can translate it as
Hatred or anger never comes to end with the reaction of hatred and anger.
Not in this world, not ever, not at any time.
And it's only through goodwill, through understanding compassion that they come to cease.
So this is an eternal law.
This is an absolute law.
I can only hope my words have been of some assistance, that they have not caused even greater confusion.
And that by your devotion to the practice, you will be liberated from all suffering sooner rather than later.